يحرصوا عرفان الله على الحضور يوميا لفصله
الدراسي رغم اعاقته ورغم برد كابل القارس
[موسيقى]
واتيت في هذا البرد نعم الا تشعر بالبرد
اشعر به كثيرا ومع ذلك اتيت نعم
في هذا البرد القارس وعلى الارض وفي اوحال
يجلس هؤلاء الاطفال ليتعلموا محبه العلم
تعني كما يقولها هؤلاء الاطفال
لا توجد في هذه المنطقه الواقعه في
الضواحي الشرقيه للعاصمه كابول مدرسه
حكوميه ولا اهليه ولهذا يضطر الاطفال
لتحمل هذه الصعاب للحصول على قدر من العلم
وزير خان الذي بدا هذا المشروع التعليمي
يقول ان الوضع الاقتصادي الصعب لا يسمح له
ولا لاهالي المنطقه بتقديم خدمات تعليميه
افضل لهؤلاء الاطفال
ارجوكم
اريد ان اوسع هذا المشروع في المستقبل الى
34 مقاطعه من مقاطعه البلد ويشاركني عشرون
من الشباب المتطوعين حتى تتعلم كل بنات
افغانستان وشبابها
هؤلاء الاطفال بنينا وبنات يواصلون
دراستهم من اجل بناء مستقبليهم وذلك على
الرغم من صعوبه الظروف التي يتعلمون فيها
حيث لا تقفى البرد في هذه الايام التي تصل
الدرجه البروده خلالها في كابول 20 درجه
تحت الصفر عبد الا نادر العربيه كابول